in july we usually go down to san diego
for a week of shows
at comic-con obviously this year
comic-con did not happen
because of covid however that did not
stop
our friends at funko the company that
makes
pop vinyl figures from once again
creating
five new limited edition
conan pop figures yes
five check them out there is uh yours
truly as
wonder woman right there little uh got
the lasso and everything
you've got uh oh this is cool
um conan as chucky which sadly just
looks like me yeah no real difference
mini conan yeah uh here's
conan as marty mcfly
yes that's a good one you gotta have
that one
here's uh conan as aquaman
i'm fierce in this one i've got a
trident and everything yeah
look out he'll swim at you
[Laughter]
and then look at this sexy pose conan as
dr
ian malcolm look at that
that is a sensual doll oh is that like
the jeff goldblum
yeah jeff goldblum jurassic park look at
that and guess what
this is now the second most sensual doll
i own
oh boy okay these are collectible
vinyl figures that we normally give out
at comic con instead
we're giving them away to our viewers
over the next two weeks
a special code will be shown each night
during conan
to enter go to tbs.com conan pop
enter that night's code see if you're an
instant winner
fans also have a second chance to win by
following team coco on instagram
facebook and twitter
gang you gotta get these think of it
someday
your family is gonna have to remove
these from your house after you
die and find some use for them it's
exciting